it's a whole new year and you
PlayStation Plus subscribers can start
your 2018 off right with more free games
if you want to know what you can grab
this January I've got you covered
first stop ps4 is getting Deus Ex
mankind divided the latest in the
dystopian adventure series sees you once
again playing as whatever version of
Adam Jensen you choose whether that
means guns blazing going stealth or
trying your hand at hacking and you can
flip between all those skills to stop
the terrorist group threatening the
world ps4 is also getting the complete
first season of Batman the telltale
series this narrative adventure game is
Telltale's own spin on the Caped
Crusader with an original villain and
twists on the typical Batman stories
over the course of five episodes but
wait there's more Sony's celebration of
PlayStation VR continues with another
free game star blood arena if you've got
the headset you can strap into a variety
of ships for some outerspace dogfighting
or take flight with a friend and co-op
on the ps3 side you can take a swing
with sacred 3 this hack-and-slash game
let's you do battle with a bunch of
unique classes and take the combat
online to fight in four player co-op you
just might need the help battling an
evil emperor and his legion of demons
what if combat isn't your thing you can
also dive into the point-and-click
adventure book of unwritten tales to
animals and objects in the land of
aven't Asia our mysteriously
transforming into other things and
you'll play as four different heroes
trying to reverse this strange magic as
for the Vita Sony's handheld is getting
psycho-pass mandatory happiness if
you're a fan of the anime you probably
know what to expect here for everyone
else this is a visual novel set in a
dystopian Tokyo where people can be
preemptively arrested for future crimes
finally Vita owners can also solve
puzzles and uncanny valley
your choices really matter as you
explore a huge facility and your actions
can result in any one of multiple
endings and thanks to cross by this Vita
title is also available on ps4 and those
are your free PS Plus games for January
2018 they're available right now through
February 5th you can always check out
gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles over at
gamespot and if you want to keep up with
all of our top stories you can grab the
official game spot now app on iOS and
Android
you